you just watch if you thought oh they
were just treating trump a certain way
because trump grabbed him by the [ __ ]
and trump is orange and trump this that
and the other thing it's like watch what
they will do to anyone else and the
reason that the media hated trump so
much is trump fought back but i think
desantis has actually learned a matrix
style oh i know what does he what does
he say in matrix neo oh i know
i know jiu jitsu is that the line i know
karate or jiu jitsu now yeah i think
that's what desantis basically has been
doing but all of this leads to that
biden what's this really about
is that really people realize biden is a
disaster they realize nobody likes
kamala that this thing is falling apart
fast so the ladies of the view continue
and they hypothesize about what
democrats should run in 2024 i hate this
talk about i think people saying that
he's too old i mean you know if the
former you know twice impeached
disgraced president thinks he he's such
a young spring chicken i mean he's going
to be 78 uh when when joe biden is 81
and so i don't like this ageism argument
but i will say
when he was here i asked him he works
out every day yeah i don't think trump
does take a look yeah i mean take a look
exactly yeah but but i do think there
are plenty of you know um democrats that
that have uh tons of verve and energy i
mean i like gavin newsom because he's
really pretty to look at and i think he
does a great job in california um i like
kamala kamala and pete buddhija i love
tickets i think that looks great do you
think they could win really well i would
vote for them i hope this country is
ready for something like that
i think the brain power alone would
would just uh obliterate
trump or and i would just love to
it's not just
that sonny hassan is the most unpleasant
person really the most deeply unpleasant
person on television and that's a quite
a statement i mean she sits usually on a
panel with anna navarro i mean these are
deeply unpleasant you know judgmental
really just the awful
that that thing that that so many people
now think about liberals this sort of
elite smug
unpleasant
awfulness right
it's not just that she's that she's also
an idiot i mean she's just an idiot now
first off
gavin newsom
gavin newsom gavin newsom has almost
single-handedly destroyed
california and now i will put more money
in the jar gavin newsom has caused
california for the first time in the
history of california
to lose
population for the last two years for
the first time ever okay
almost 300 000 people have fled
california
its main cities san francisco los
angeles are dystopian nightmares crime
is rampant homeless this is rampant okay
you know all of that so she likes what
he's done and he's pretty to look at yes
he does have slick hair i'll give him
that
there i finally could say something nice
about avenues i don't even like his hair
i'm just saying he has slick pat
riley-esque
you know 1987 lakers hair okay fine uh
so she goes on about that and then who
does she want to run well she likes pete
and kamala now kamala is an airhead
kamala what do we know about kamala what
does kamala know kamala know that russia
big ukraine small that is the extent of
the brain power as she calls it and pete
pete budajeg and what do we know about
pete pete is gay pete is gay and that's
why he got the job so you have a woman
who knows that russia is big and pete
who is gay these people are not
professionals we also know that pete
went on two months paternity leave when
his kids were born and then took time
off from being transportation secretary
don't forget he's our first ever gay
transportation secretary uh in the midst
of our supply chain disaster okay by the
way i'm not taking paternity guys we're
working i don't care if there's kids
down there screaming
we're working through we're playing
through you'll be taking care of the
kids by the way um
but the brain power of kamala and pete